you know what the same wise choice of
anime these days that I started to
confuse me there now anime is about well
someone's normal life I thought the
whole point of anime and television for
that matter what's Maggi forget about
your own reality and just absorb
yourself in the show so when I start
watching shows about a fictional
characters normal boring life to make me
forget about my own normal boring life I
always complete forgot why I started
watching anime in the first place
if I wanted to experience a dreary drab
life I could eat up by just not watching
an immense doing whatever I'm supposed
to be doing or play GTA 4 again there
are also at maze with deep involves
storylines in them and I love these as
much as the next person but as the guy
sometimes there's nothing more I want to
do they're just bathed in my own
testosterone and celebrate my complete
maniiness by switching my brain and
diving into either tits guns cars or all
three
so along comes Black Lagoon an anime
with its guns and cars perfect shot is
my man hooded absolutely now I must warn
you beforehand due to the foul language
graphic content and sexual nature of
this anime if you're under 18 I cannot
recommend this show for you haha but in
all seriousness if you come into the
show wanting a slice-of-life comedy or a
deep storyline
prepare to be disappointed because this
show is pure in-your-face action from
start to finish if you really want to
story synopsis though well this guy here
named Rock and no not that one gets
himself kidnapped by pirates called the
Black Lagoon company incidentally he
likes his kidnappers so much so you
decide to join them after that stuff
happens [ __ ] get crazy and [ __ ]
starts blowing up now there you have
Black Lagoon in a nutshell see the whole
series is basically like some summer
Hollywood action movie blockbuster sorry
got [ __ ] a geek a Chinese gangster a
stoner a samurai a crazy made a crazy
nut a crazy chick a crazy chick a crazy
[ __ ] Russian chick and 50 cent
this all-star cast makes up a brilliant
series compares to those insane action
flicks such as die hard or the
Terminator and yes this series is filled
with cliches but in a good way I mean
just look at the main crew you have
benny the typical computer guy dodged a
big black walking stereotype rock the
calm composed dude and Rebbie the crazy
chick with guns though i never restore
the point of characters like her I mean
all she's there for is to stand in the
frame of every shot showing off bits of
skin while she's striking most sexual
post possible as she fires her shots
while she's parading around her taste
which jiggle endlessly up and down and
up and down and no I just answered my
own question there I just also have to
it's rock for his intuitive skill of
sensing how other people are feeling
right shit-for-brains the only [ __ ]
reason we're not dead right now is
because for some [ __ ] reason that
[ __ ] war maniac [ __ ] put her gun
away or maybe it was God's grace or your
great sense of humor yeah I agreed to be
your gun while we were here but this is
[ __ ] I could protect you through the
[ __ ] Alamo but it's just not [ __ ]
possible to protect a guy who's trying
so damn hard to get [ __ ] killed all
the time
are you mad but I'm getting off topic
here the main crew isn't even the best
part by the show that licking is one of
the few shows I can do story arcs that
don't revolve around main cast and still
be interesting in fact one of the best
arcs are the ones that revolve around by
the licker such as the arts with a crazy
killer ancestral vampire twins yes you
heard that right crazy killer incestual
vampire twins I wish I could make this
[ __ ] up the series also has a we're
building up all that adrenaline stored
in your body to a point where you feel
like you need to exert it all at once by
either flipping tables punching walls or
just greeting Wadley fluids and if you
use latter of the methods then I suggest
that you stuck up on underwear for
example there's this one scene where the
crew manages to launch their torpedo
boat off a makeshift ramp to the air
only to successfully hit a surprise
mercenary piloting an airborne assault
helicopter with normally aquatic
torpedoes yes the scene was his cliche
stupid and impractical as it sounded but
it was [ __ ] awesome the series has a
way of making you forget about the whole
unrealistic nature of the show and a set
times you to an ancient sink headed
Neanderthal shouting at the slightest
prospect of blood and I bloody love it
for that I would like to mention the
dubbing in the series for the records I
do usually like to watched animes done
anyway but I just have to say that the
dubbing a series is basically right on
the spot and really was that [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
brilliant and as you saw has more
swearing than Gordon Ramsay on a bad day
in my opinion it's even better than the
Japanese version since it has more of an
international appeal to it considering
that only one of the characters is
actually Japanese overall Black Lagoon
is one hell of a show that shouldn't be
missed if you're an action fan the
animation is beautiful the dubbing is
brilliant and there are scenes in this
that will kick your balls so hard that
you'll have to piss out your mouth even
though there are many cliches present
and there is no real overlayed storyline
or negative thoughts can be overlooked
because this show contains crazy killer
in sexual vampire twins overall I give
this and they a 9 out of 10
you